almost 200 relief centers across Phoenix
are offering people and pets say hi an
escape from the deadly heat baking the
temperatures topped 110 degrees for the
13th day in a row Wednesday officials
say the top priority is hydration by the
time you're thirsty it's too late is
Phoenix's director of heat response and
mitigation AKA The Heat Czar what's the
first thing people need to do in heat
like this well from a public health
perspective the first thing we advise is
pay attention to your body signs of heat
illness include dizziness weakness and
nausea the blistering heat stretches
across the south from Texas it's hotter
and hotter every summer time to Southern
California where temps could top 113
degrees this weekend to give you an idea
of how this heat lingers the low temp at
night has been in the 90s for the past
three days and the record is seven
consecutive days